so I'll say a little bit about my story
and who I am I'm a fashion photographer
based in New York City I've worked for
lots of different magazines and in New
York I've worked for
Elle and for a Marie Claire and for
interview and for GQ and with some
really beautiful people like my Studios
in New York but I also lived in Milan
for about eight years and worked in
Paris as Rawling work for the house of
you Celeron did also did portraiture as
well cook would like to skip that
shove-it we go back so we did lots of
different I've worked for lots of
different magazines lots of great
clients and but I was always told every
single day who was beautiful I was
forced to work within certain parameters
of the beauty standard I was told this
is the most amazing model of the moment
you've got to photograph her she's
incredible and you gotta chefs and then
the next season it would change again
and I have to shift my ideas of beauty
and she's go to the next model and it
was kind of really crazy because I saw
I'm an artist
I saw Beauty everywhere I didn't see
Beauty just on a magazine cover I I did
I did a shoot with of course India for
Revlon and really fantastic beautiful
people but I thought you know what
someone's always telling me who's
beautiful and I was kind of frustrating
I left my studio one afternoon in New
York I was walking down Park Avenue and
I'm still waiting for a bus at the
corner of Park and 20th this gorgeous
kid she had long white beautiful hair
pale pale skin she had a genetic
condition called albinism didn't know
much about it but she was stunning and I
never met a model like this before and I
went to grab her said I have to take
your photograph you're amazing and the
bus came she got on and she took off and
I was really glad because she was 12 and
I'd be in prison at the moment it is
extraordinary to see this kid so I
continued right down to Union Square to
the huge Barnes & Noble started pulling
any books or any information I could
about this genetic condition albinism
and I felt like really kind of sad
images I didn't find images of this kid
I found images of people sitting in
hospital beds looking sad looking
downtrodden look at just images of
despair I found images of a bright red
hi
the albino eye I'm thinking this kid had
beautiful
blugh I shouldn't have red eyes and then
I started saying images from Africa
where kids were surrounded by tribes
pointing Spears at them are in in cancer
wards and clinics or they're just in
beds and images of illness of sadness of
sickness and then I started of course
going through those same medical
textbooks instead of finding these
typical images of kids and adults in
their underwear against walls and
doctors offices with the black bar cross
their eyes saying disease this is a
disease defined by a disease I was like
this is crazy and then I started going
into further looking in the internet and
all these different medical textbooks
and everything was so sad and so
negative I haven't started finding
images of the albino freak family in the
circus and then of course all the movie
references from powder who had albinism
as his mother was struck by lightening
lightening to the Princess Bride and to
I think the Matrix Reloaded there were
the ghost-like twins that came in and
wreaked havoc and and destroyed things
and then disappeared even most recently
The Da Vinci Code was like the evil
albino driving around Paris and like
killing people shooting at people well I
found out through my research that
people with albinism have a visual
impairment
there's always vision but they're
considered legally blind so they
certainly wouldn't be driving around
Paris at night shooting at anybody in
expect to hit anything something this is
crazy
so I contact Noah now Noah is the
National Organization for albinism and
hypopigmentation it's a support group
for people living with this condition
and their families and I'm like hey I'm
the fashion photographer let's show the
world the beauty of albinism and they
said get lost and I'm ready for a system
like what are you talking and they said
they made it very clear to me about
their fears of exploitation that every
time there was a magazine article that
came out about a kid with albinism it
was a story about a victim it was sad or
was exploitative or sensational never
positive always negative I said okay
well then what do we do Harrison
so let's form a non-traditional
partnership fashion photographer genetic
support group and we'll work together
and you can keep an eye on me to make
sure that we create something positive
and powerful showing the world the
beauty of albinism and they said okay
and I was like fantastic let's
this so in walked the first person
without the photograph her name is
Christine and Christine is a knock out
long white hair really tall she's
stunning she walks into my studio don't
wait up she walks in though instead of
this gorgeous girl she walks in like
this her heads down shoulders hunched
one-word answer she looks with no eye
contact this kid has been teased her
whole life because of her difference and
it was so apparent on the fact that it
left her with zero zero self-esteem I'm
thinking uh this kid is so she's just so
so fragile and just the day before I was
shooting Cindy in the Saints on the same
set in my studio I'm thinking well I
have to be have to be so careful with
that No out of respect for this gorgeous
kid I want to photograph her like I
would anybody else so the fan went on
the music went on and I grabbed a mirror
that was next to the set and I held it
up to her and I said Christine you know
fix yourself you're magnificent and she
looked in the mirror and she got it if
she went from this and that's art
Christine she just exploded in front of
it but she was all over by the time she
left the studio she was kissing
everybody on both cheeks and saying ciao
and she was unbelievable and I saw this
transformation right in front of the
lens through photography that she was
now transferred with a powerful and
positive sense of who she is
the next day she goes to school she's
going to change the way her community
sees her difference instead of walking
into that classroom like this she's
walking in like this so it's all about
ambassadors for change it was
extraordinary in those first images of
red have to be to be did a series of
images on several individuals with this
syndrome had this condition was in life
they were in Life magazine in 1998 so a
while ago was that cover story it was a
five-page spread it was really a
fantastic editorial it was great I loved
it then we used a lot of the images
though from life put them in make other
magazines magazines worldwide magazines
in the UK in France and Italy Canada
there were and other magazines in the
States it was amazing so it's from the
UK Cristina again friend Danny Ruthie
her sisters and Kristin let's not lower
we did
campaign for sunglasses a lot of kids
with this condition have our photo
phobic so they have a real strong light
sensitivity so we thought perfect for an
eyeglass campaign a sunglass campaign Oh
People magazine did a great story so
it's really little circulating things
were people were saying all this great
stuff it was fantastic so I was getting
calls up getting calls from the UK
saying well we just saw this spread can
you come and photograph our kids with
this condition can you come in we have a
support group here can you come with me
and our families but you will in Africa
we're doing calling the same newsela can
you have a start a support group I'm
like fantastic this is great let's do it
so I would travel all these places and
as I was shooting and doing my
commercial work I was at a local chapter
conference in Philadelphia small family
conference about 40 families did my
presentation of kids with albinism this
mom came up came up to me she said you
know my son Randy when he was a little
boy he'd come home from school and I
could see the kids were teasing him and
he'd be in tears and I buy him an ice
cream color or a toy truck and he'd
forget about it she said now he's in
high school he comes home from school I
could see the pain the anguish in his
eyes he walks in he comes ghost walks
and walks right past me goes up his room
slams the door and I don't see him until
the next day she said he's not gonna
want to be funnier Oh self-esteem this
can is such poor body image and he's
just it's so it's he's just so shy
but if you could just show him
photographs of kids his own age so that
he knows he's not alone like of course
where is he show me she points over to
Randy enough Randy Center his pants are
hanging down to here his underwear is
hanging out he has this long great big
show you have 10 earrings as a tattoo
he's amazing this kid I crawl over to
Rendon like Randy I speak to moms and
dads every single day terrified about
the future of their kids with albinism
all they have to do is take one look at
you and they're going to be fun please
let me take their favor
your mother said and she told me that
you didn't wanna be footing he's like
wait wait he's the Rick what do you mean
I can't Lisa but you have to understand
I'm 16 years old I don't talk to my
mother and then
ladies I want to be photographed I want
to show the world but who are you with
my Alvin ISM but also other things don't
you feel shy he was very very shy Rena
but Randy created early days in this
idea this nonprofit group positive
exposure the idea of networking story
sharing experiences and the images
around the world Oh quickly go through
up albums I'm sorry I'm very interested
at that point getting calls from
everybody in the world to find out more
about this idea a message about albinism
our perceptions of people in communities
about the syndrome albinism
so I started hearing about stigmas and
discrimination and I actually so what I
looked at is really kind of explore
cultural perceptions and attitudes
towards this condition this is my friend
Gladys mirror who's a Kuna Indian in the
same loss region of the world and the
sandbox region of the center of Panama
she's extraordinary so the incidence of
albinism is about one in 20,000
worldwide and the Kuna Indian it's
someone in 125 the highest incidence in
the world we went to Fiji actually where
we found out to turn in the 19th century
a tribe could not hold their territory
let's say it's somebody with albinism in
a powerful political position in a cat
game my great friend Kiki I photographed
in New Zealand she's from from India
from New Delhi from Delhi but she her
family left Delhi because she was
getting death threats now I'm thinking
this is horrible they haven't moved
she's 8 years old and we actually
started the support group in Delhi and
found out that there are many kids that
we worked with in their communities
after we started this group in India
that have had really positive
experiences so one of the things were
making sure we make very clear is that
we're not making generalizations about a
community or a culture and their
reaction to people that are different
techies experiences were very different
but we met many kids there that had been
embraced by their communities throughout
India a great friend out Sumana from
Korea Tom who was just adopted by an
American family from China it's my great
friend Harry from Puerto Rico
Natalia she and I started the first
albinism society in Russia my Zhaan and
her sister and mom in Malaysia
pyaara pyaara all she ever wanted to do
is be a dancer she was told that because
of her visual
she'll never dance so never be able to
follow the choreography or the dance
steps never she's like us but to me
she's like they said find another love
another passion she's like no she's New
Zealand's Celtic dance champion and just
started a school for dance for kids with
visual impairment
my grandmother zipped through this Roz
from Australia it lets a lot of time in
Africa with us a high incidence and
mortality associated with albinism due
to skin cancer that's my friend ciri who
when she was born the father the
father's family put her out how things
she was cursed put her out of the house
and and mom not knowing what to do put
ciri in the Sun to get her dark like her
brothers and sisters so it's all sun
damage this is a great frame a lot of
kids I met it throughout Africa we were
put in schools special schools schools
for the blind not because of the tools
are better there for kids with visual
impairment but more importantly because
the teasing was so great this
discrimination is so great these kids
don't do well in mainstream schools
I started in albinism society in Kenya
with my friend CK who actually went to a
mainstream school like seek and how is
it possible you went to a mainstream
school nobody in Africa goes the
mainstream schools she said it's because
of my twin sister Daphne like fantastic
she said yeah that's me we get all the
work off the board the thing is I
couldn't see she'd help me with him and
then with the pipe was too small she'd
blow it up for me she said but more
importantly when kids would tease me
Daphne would beat them up smellin
Saturno time spending a lot of time in
Tanzania where witch doctors are saying
bring me the bones of an albino and I'll
make a potion that will make you rich so
we're working very closely with the
government there they would have been
there six times in the last two years to
really kind of create programs public
awareness programs to save these kids
it's kind of go quickly through so I
received the of the dancer this isn't a
Shenyang no reason these are one of the
visuals that we created in in Africa in
East Africa trying to fight in and kind
of educate the public um this is
actually I've received the art of
reporting award from the an organization
called the chromosome 18 registry and it
was actually a larger organization sorry
it was like genetic Alliance which was a
coalition of all the genetic support
groups and it was the award for the life
magazine piece the president at the time
said I'm also the founder and director
of the chromosome 18 Research Society at
registry like and
that's great what time you know if you
have a an anomaly anomaly on your 18th
chromosome then you have all kinds of
problems and difficulties and challenges
and you and then we look after you as
this is through this support group like
Noah is some likes great she's like well
she said I see there's a universal
message here about all kids with
differences so it's not just about
albinism would you come and speak to our
families in San Antonio with these
chromosome 18 anomalies I'm like sure I
went back to thinking how does a
chromosome 18 anomaly I was an art major
at the School of Visual Arts I had no
idea but I looked it up and looked and
these are the images that I saw I'm
thinking I have anism was so easy this
is gonna be rough but I went San Antonia
walk down to the auto turn with the kids
and young adults were open the door and
I was instantly surrounded by kids
screaming with laughter there were kids
with with cleft palates kids with
mobility issues feeding tubes tricks but
they were kids first and foremost that's
Rebecca and Pauline my great friend
that's Ellington he's awesome
Remy Emery Byron Taylor Elizabeth it's
just some of my great friends Sean is it
so we decided at that point to involve
other organizations to be part of this
larger exhibition that was going to be
sent out that the the bring the people's
genome celebration in 2001 they invited
me to the National Human Genome Research
Institute and the genetic lines invited
me to create an exhibition at the
Smithsonian commemorating the mapping of
the human genome so we actually invited
other genetic support groups to be part
of this exhibition not just on albinism
but all groups again illustrating the
universal applicability I saw these
images in the marfan foundation these
kids grow very very tall at risk of an
aortic dissection but they're amazing
case I think that how of course I
understood the importance of this image
how important it was to show how
beautiful I mean to show how the image
presents itself but isn't there another
way to show up because nobody I my
photograph thousands of kids now with
more offense in him and nobody stands
like this with the portable black bar
it's just it's extraordinary so we
decided to put him in a pool show Billy
swimming show helped me on how it
presents itself but keep going and keep
presenting how how these kids look and
but putting humanity back in these
gorgeous images well I only have a few
it's the seconds here so I'm gonna kind
of go through cool girls at the Costello
conference these are great friends of
Danielle and Maggie who actually met at
Les Costello conference they both first
time they ever met anybody with the same
syndrome but and they go to the same
conferences every year and I go and
photograph them and this year they were
there again in Florida but this time
it's a little different they have them
they're gangsters now but they're pretty
amazing kids
I just want to quickly go and touch our
friend briefly about this really great
kid he's just so sorry I didn't know I
was gonna go on so of but I just wanna
talk very briefly about a project that
we're taking these images and bring them
in the high schools making I can
photograph a great kid in my studio and
she's having a brilliant time and she
feels up to thousand feet tall but time
she leaves in my studio and gets to Park
Avenue that five people point at her
point at her birthmark red or white hair
or her wheelchair so we have to make it
relevant for all of us for all these
kids to make people understand another
some of the idea of celebrating
diversity actually means so we started a
project called the pearls product where
these kids are photographs are going
into high schools and the kids that are
in the images are blogging and the
students are following their blogs and
they all have these brain if video
intros I'm just going to give you this
last one and this is actually Byron who
is excellent one of our bloggers my name
is Byron I live in the DC area on 14th
when I was 10 months old I had a left
hemisphere xme um I had the left half of
my brain removed because I of us i have
something called sturge-weber syndrome i
wear a brace on the on my right leg and
right arm i only see out of the right
side of each eye
so sometimes it's harder for me to see
some see things on the right side so
playing sports can be frustrating
because i might not see a ball coming I
didn't see that these are the images so
we're using all the visual arts that
change public perceptions through these
great kids I feel as an artist it's my
responsibility to I know that when I was
a kid I saw someone but that was
different walking down the street I was
if I stare like that
left by my mom so the idea was either he
if you don't don't stare it look away
and I think as an artist it's my
responsibility and all of our
responsibilities to steady that gaze a
little bit longer loner to really seek
as you stand there you'll see different
she'll you'll start seeing beauty in
that difference in the start seeing
beautiful gorgeousness and then this
light just spreads and once you're in
light and it just it changes your whole
world it's about seeing the beauty in
all differences thank you so much and
sorry roundover thank you